hey guys bandit here
um hope you're doing okay
um i like to start off these videos by
asking that uh just because i'm
genuinely curious and hope you guys are
all doing okay i'm doing well too thank
you for asking or wondering in case you
were asking or wondering
um i guess i'll just cut straight to
the point of this video
which is something that i've been
mulling over for a long time and those
of you who follow me on twitter you
probably
kind of figured out that something like
this was coming due to my recent tweets
and stuff like that
so you might know where i'm going with
this but
anyway this is um
it's not super easy to talk about but i
feel like after this the decision has
been made um i will clearly need to
explain myself
and explain the decision
to everybody who
is uh interested would be interested in
why i made this decision this may seem
like it's coming out of the blue but
trust me for me i if i'm being honest
and i'm all i'm always honest with you
guys trust me on that
uh i've been mulling over this for a
long long time
uh but it finally just kind of came to a
head
uh when i did the gt live stream over
the weekend which by the way
still
like can't believe that that actually
happened um i still think to myself like
wow one day what if i meet matpat and
then i'm like
i actually did meet matpat and i
streamed with him for hours and talked
to him directly
which was so
freaking cool and thank you to everybody
who tuned in for that but anyway back on
subject uh in that stream as a part of
that stream i was
basically reminded and convinced that
this change needs to happen and that is
that i need to do away
with mask nintendo bandit
the name and this is for several
different reasons but the primary reason
is that i no longer feel
like
the name
reflects
exactly what i'm wanting to do with this
channel and the things that i'm trying
to cover with this channel
and if you look at my previous videos
you'll see why i say that the reason why
this came to a head over the weekend is
because uh before remember i was saying
matpat is just a super chill and cool
guy and we chatted for hours well before
the stream even went live we chatted for
an entire hour just to get to know each
other and while we were chatting he
asked me uh how i came up with the name
mass antenna bandit and i told him it's
not a much of a story at all really i
was just
once upon a time i was a young kid who
came up with the name for some reason on
my personal facebook account mind you
and then you know a couple years ago
when i was making this channel
i was thinking about quirky names and
that one came to mind
and i was like okay i'll just use that
and that's really all it is but before
he even asked that when i was initially
getting the email to be on the stream
the email that was looping me together
with all of his staff members and and
people involved
the subject line of the email was a
nintendo banned it for a final stream
and at the time
when i read that email and when
eventually i was chatting with him
before the stream i i didn't really
think anything of it i mean i've always
known that my name is kind of quirky and
long and you know unique and people have
questions about like why i'm named that
when i cover the things that i do but
then the final like nail in the coffin
straw that broke the camel's back
whatever you want to call it was in the
actual stream
when he straight up asked me and you can
see this if you watch the stream you
know well are you going to rebrand to
masked fenaf bandit now and you know i
joked back i was like wouldn't it be
masked steel wool bandit and it was you
know haha we're joking whatever but
i think it finally just like clicked for
me that
my name really is kind of strange and
i've kind of branded myself with it and
made it to where people have to
genuinely ask
either why i named myself that or why
i'm covering what i'm covering
and those are both questions that i
don't necessarily want people to ask
when trying to watch my videos because
people might not even click on my videos
because it's been uploaded by a nintendo
person especially if they're trying to
watch a finaf video or an undertale
video or a deltarune video or
coming soon an elder elden ring video
sorry i'm stumbling over my words but
the fact that nintendo is in my name
isn't the only problem my name is also
just kind of long it's definitely not
the longest name on youtube space i mean
it has the same syllable count as peanut
butter gamer or nintendo black crisis
but it is long enough to where like i've
been asked by
uh other creators that i've collaborated
with if they can just omit my name from
the title because it takes over 20 wait
am i
yeah over 20 characters to put my name
in the title so it's just it's really
long and people don't even know how to
search for my channel i've seen how
people search my channel and it's either
like mask space nintendo space bandit or
which isn't my channel name and could
potentially hurt the search engine
optimization or just mnb which is also
not my name etc etc or they search
nintendo black crisis which you know
could go either way i suppose and
actually that's another point the fact
that a lot of the time i'm confused with
nintendo black crisis which has been
kind of a running joke for the past
couple years uh and actually when i was
bringing this concept up to my mods in
discord who are all amazing friends of
mine who you know i bounce ideas off of
all the time
one of them actually brought up to me
that they're pretty sure i wouldn't have
even gotten to where i am now if i
hadn't been confused with nintendo black
crisis in the early days so i mean
there's that but that still doesn't
change the problem of my name
kind of pigeonholing me in places where
i no longer want to be pigeonholed and i
could go into it a little bit more but
at this point i'm kind of rambling so
i'm just going to
stop explaining why i'm doing this and
start explaining what i'm going to do
about it so clearly i thought to myself
i need a rebrand i need to rename i need
to re do my banners i need to redo
the way that i appear on the internet
but there were things i did not want to
do away with one of which and primarily
was the namesake of bandit
because i am banned that's who i am i
don't think i'm ever going to not be
banned
uh but
given that i'm not trying to do away
with the name bandit how then was i
going to redo my name
into something that would reflect my
content i i went over all sorts of
things like bandits hideout or just
masked banned it
uh or just banned it just just banned it
um and all of them either looked
visually weird or just didn't feel right
or
was just missing something so eventually
i came up with bandit games and the more
that i say it to myself the more
i like it to be honest with you because
my two channels will now be banned at
games and bandit plays one will be about
the scripted lore videos and the other
will be about
the unscripted gameplay let's plays and
stuff like that so more lore based and
then more personality-based bandit games
and bandit plays and i kind of really
like it to be honest and the reason why
i'm making this video is because i need
to explain myself
to myself honestly because this is
really sad for me and hard to talk about
because the name mass antenna bandit is
so nostalgic for me and
it is the name sorry it's a little dusty
i haven't wiped it down in a while but
as you can see that doesn't say bandit
games that says mass intent to ban it so
this will always be
my first name and it'll always be so
special to me and i'm sure for those of
you who have followed me for a while and
who might enjoy me in addition to my
content it's going to be kind of
nostalgic for you too and it's going to
be kind of sad for you too so i just
wanted to make this video explaining
what i'm doing why i'm doing it and
before i end i'm going to answer just a
quick few questions that i think some of
you might have the first of which is
does this mean i'm not going to be
covering zelda anymore and let me answer
that real quick in the first place i
never had zelda in my name yet i still
covered zelda and in the second place
out of all of the franchises that i love
and will be covering because i love them
because
recently my mindset has been like you
know i'll play these other games and
i'll have a question about lore or
something like that and i'll search
online and like nobody's covered what
i'm searching for and then i'll think to
myself why don't i just cover that and
that's the primary reason for my
branching out into these other
franchises
but of all the franchises that i love to
play and that i do play
on the top will always be the legend of
zelda that is the franchise that has
shaped who i am i mean do you see my
background you see that little
link doll right there you see my
nintendo 64. you see my map of hyrule
you see my custom link art that one of
my friends made for me do you see my
shirt
oh you see my shirt you see my mug
my dog's name is gannon so clearly i'm
not going to stop covering zelda zelda's
always going to have a huge presence on
the channel it's just that i need to
make room
and i need to clear expectations so that
i can cover whatever i want to cover
without misleading anybody or
disappointing anybody and the other
question i'm sure is when are these
changes going to be going live because
i'm sure you noticed my channel is still
called mass nintendo bandit that's a
good question
i am going to be going live with this
when i can go live with the entire
rebrand which is going to include uh new
cover art or i'm sorry new banner art i
don't know if it's a cover or banner
whatever new banner art i'm pretty sure
i'm going to keep the same profile
picture but you know if the banner just
looks super different then i might redo
the profile picture as well but i
haven't decided on that just yet but
that is when i'm going to go live with
the new name and all that stuff because
i have these ideas for some quirky kind
of cool looking banner uh art pieces
that i'm really excited for you guys to
see but obviously i am not
talented enough in two-dimensional art
to make that stuff myself so i'm working
with some fantastic artists on twitter
uh instagram talking to some of them
trying to get uh some art commissioned
for the channel anyway that'll be going
live hopefully within the next like week
or two before i start doing like elden
ring stuff
anyway i'm pretty sure that covers
everything i wanted to talk
about pretty sure
i could definitely be forgetting
something right now but if i think of
something else i'll put it in like a
comment below and if you guys have
questions for me about the channel
please put in the comments below
ultimately this is not going to really
have any huge effect on the content that
i make i'm still going to do
primarily theories i'm going to do lore
dives i'm going to do top tens i'm i'm
going to do i mean potentially reviews
in the future all sorts of scripted
content is going to happen right here
it's just going to happen on bandit
plays
hey guys future editing bandit here i
made a mistake in the video i did not
mean that it's going to be happening on
bandit plays i meant to say bandit games
okay here's future editing bandit
signing out instead of mass and 10
abandoned cool
not a big deal unless you're me and
you're really sappy and emotional and
connected to the original name so i
probably just made this video to pep
talk myself into doing it
ultimately but anyway just wanted to
upload this for anybody else who might
also be interested in why i'm doing this
sort of thing
that's it that's all uh so thank you
guys so much for continuing to watch my
stuff uh
leave a like on this video if you enjoy
the direction i'm going or leave a
dislike if you don't just so i kind of
know the consensus out there and
subscribe if you haven't already for all
the cool stuff that we are going to be
making on this channel together you and
i that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
what's up everyone masked nintendo
bandit here bringing you a theory video
and this one's about zelda which just
happens to be my favorite subject by the
way i mean i could make a whole video
dedicated